the 14 inch m1 max macbook pro actually  throttles the performance quite a bit  compared to the 16 inch model for  example the gpu clock speed on the 14  inch will not go higher than around 11  36 megahertz no matter what even if the  temperatures are cool and you're plugged  into power we weren't able to get more  than 35 watts of power flowing to the 14  inch m1 max's gpu compared to as high as  43 watts on the 16 inch model which of  course leads to faster performance  across the board as you can see in the  gfx bench graphics test and based on all  of the other tests that we ran the  biggest performance difference we saw  was when we tested cinebench and 3dmark  wildlife at the same time and the  16-inch ended up being 37 percent faster  which is a huge job but don't get me  wrong the 14-inch is still more than  powerful enough for almost everyone and  is by far the fastest laptop in its size  and weight class